[Music]
hi I'm Kelly Tran I just finished a
chemistry for Star Wars I feel crazy
I want to go back to when you actually
got the call because we've read a lot of
like you know you were maybe thinking
about quitting acting and you were you
were doing your comedy thing and then
you get the call of all calls and then
you have to just go back to work so what
was that walk us through that moment
uh-huh yeah so I had been auditioning
for this movie for about five months I
like it I say we bring him along but
what do you think doc are you don't
trust him I trust we don't have to trust
him we just have to believe he'll do
what he says he'll do okay literally the
definition of the word trust
it was actually an in person like
meeting with Ryan and I was my day job
and I got a call from a agent saying
that Ryan wanted to meet with me before
we all went home for Thanksgiving so
this is November of 2015 before the
force awakens comes out Wow yes you
should remember that I was auditioning
for this movie and waiting to hear back
while all the marketing for force
awakens was coming out so it was him I
tried to get out of my head but it was
everywhere it was so insane so I go to
this meeting with Ryan and I tell my my
co-workers that I'm going on my lunch
break and they go to this meeting Ryan
tells me god I remember that day like it
was yesterday it's just so crazy
I remember driving there and just like
shaking cuz I was just thinking to
myself either he's gonna say you have
this or he's gonna say nice try kid like
yeah I'm really really really
she has like Rose stepped up for me the
character I had in my head when I was
writing it was like she showed up serene
and so I get there and there's like a
little bit of small talk and then he
says Kelly I want to offer you this role
and I had imagined this moment so many
times and I thought that I would be
ecstatic I thought that I'd be jumping
up and down but I was just shocked and
quiet for maybe a full minute or two I'm
saying are you excited yeah yeah exactly
he goes so do you uh and I was just like
I'm sorry yes but what it's just such a
it was so shocking the whole thing um
and then he was like well you can't tell
anyone so what are you gonna do to
celebrate and I said I actually have to
get back to work so I'm just gonna do
that so I just went back to my day job
and answered emails and answered phone
calls like it all I did may the force be
with you Wow
[Music]
you
[Music]